Living Things.
Living things are all around us.
We are living things.
Animals are living things.
Plants are living things too.
What makes something a living thing?
Living things eat, breathe, grow and make more of itself.
Can you think of an example of a living thing?
Animals are living things.
There are many different types of animals.
They all look different.
But they all have one thing in common.
They are all living things.
Humans are living things too.
And so are plants.
Plants are living things because they breathe, eat, grow, and make more of themselves.
Plants need food and water to live.
Non-living things do not eat, breathe, grow or make more of themselves.